We're all getting old.
Yes, even you.
More and more of our population are over sixty,...
...some living well into their nineties.
And as we live longer, our joints, organs and tissues begin to fail,...
...thereby diminishing the quality of our old age,...
...not to mention the societal cost of lost productivity and long-term care.
Our current medical technologies allow for extraordinary feats...
...of augmentation and replacement: transplantation, pacemakers and artificial joints.
Regenerative medicine goes further,...
...promising the repair of dysfunctional body parts with our own living tissue.
Many species can regenerate.
A salamander can regrow its limbs, tail and even its eye.
But sadly, only a few bits of us, like a healthy liver, can perform that trick.
Coaxing the rest of our body to do it requires more effort.
3D-printed biomaterial scaffolds coated with layers of the patient's cells...
...and cooked up in a body-mimicking oven...
...can produce viable veins, bladders and bone.
And more complex organs like kidneys aren't far away.